how's it going everybody welcome to the
show my name is Tim Poole joining me
today is famous youtuber Arielle
Scarcella the most hated lesbian on
YouTube there you go it's easiest way to
explain who you are and the subject of
this podcast I guess I don't know I
don't know how to describe what it is
you are planning on doing leaving the
left oh my god
I guess that's the best way to put it
I'm announcing it tomorrow but
officially announcing it here first we
officially announced it just I feel
honored you give a baby you have a big
youtube channel yeah how many scoops
Travis new subscribers do 630 so you're
you're a good sized youtuber talking oh
you too alright 2000-2009
so we're gonna dive into this because we
got some hit pieces on miss Arielle
Scarcella if you guys want to happen the
super chat we will I will do my best to
make sure we get your super chat
comments because what normally when we
do just a regular show with segments
it's really easy to jump over but since
you know Arielle and I are gonna be
talking about a ton of stuff we'll do
our best to try and grab the super chat
so we can but I don't want to over
promise for everybody else if you want
to get the show the full show every day
we put it up in the community section in
the morning around 7 or 8 a.m.
click the join button down below and
let's not waste any more time so i i
i've known you for a while yeah you know
we did it we did a show together a
couple years ago talking about a lot of
similar things ya know it's just gotten
10 times worse yeah ten times worse yeah
well I you know I want to feel hopeful
that the craziness of the left was like
going away but in some areas is not I
think it is I think in some areas
getting better like when you have like
Dave Chappelle and Joe Rogan push back I
think we need more people that have big
audiences we need them to speak out
because no nobody wants to be canceled
no one wants to lose brand deals so
everyone's just either ignoring it not
even touching on topics that are
important to talk about yeah or just
pretending to go along with it while
actually agreeing with what I've been
saying the whole time there and not and
not actually saying it so so let's let's
start from the beginning a lot to go
through I saw this this news article
from a news gerd certified website
called pink news we call them you can
say it yeah go for it we call them penis
news yeah it's a site run
mainly by gay men and there a lot of
their head pieces are about like
thrashing with women or lesbians
here's what I normally tell people like
don't swear but if you do it's not a big
deal I don't care it's just like we try
because no I know that's why I'm saying
I care you know so but but seriously
what a lot of people don't realize is
this craziness that comes from the left
which is resulting in you're like it's
sent me cancellation like you're getting
cancelled or something I've been trying
to cancel me for years they're not gonna
cancel me well I mean like you got
booted from an event I got I did get
booed it well they cancelled Sydney
Mardi Gras took the event off of their
page well slow down let's go back right
let's so exactly the story I saw says
Sydney Mardi Gras scraps event because
of backlash over transphobic youtuber
Arielle Scarcella so you're a member of
the LGBTQ community yeah with a big
channel talking on all the stuff and you
got the boot because now you're a
transphobic I've been called transphobic
and I've been called a turf for the last
I would say five years since about 2013
when I started making trans related
content the majority of my videos in the
beginning when I talked about trans
topic I had trans people in the videos
and I would still get hate I didn't say
the right words I didn't you know use
the right phrasing and you know I've
never missed gendered anybody not
purposely anyway even when I'm talking
about them in private even if I don't
like them because right and I mean I've
gotten nothing honestly nothing but but
support from I would say the older LGBT
community but these young woke kids that
are think that they're crazy enlightened
and it's it's just become a ridiculous
amount of more as we call a moral
superiority point-scoring like who's the
most woke oh well if you're not
pansexual and you won't date anybody you
must be a bigot or you must be
transphobic or you must be biphobic if
you don't want to date a bisexual person
which in some ways could be possible
this is interesting because I I talk
about a bit of this stuff sometimes for
me typical typically when I talk about
how life is going crazy I'm more
political so it's like watching the
Democratic debates and I'm like these
people have lost their minds
you're more entrenched in culture the
LGBT cultural left/right political
gender identity and it's just it's
gotten too much the most volatile this
way for everyone that's that's watching
just to make sure they don't leave the
stream it's gotten to the point where
where people on the Left you know the
walk left these these career activists
will call them so I don't identify as
queer but the queer activist section of
the community if you tell somebody like
let's say let's say you identify as you
look like yourself Tim but you identify
as a lesbian and you're dating another
guy somebody another seemingly a guy
that looks like you who also identifies
as a woman they would call you a lesbian
couple like this is where we've got like
like fine if you want an ID that way but
self-id mix it it doesn't even it
doesn't make sense first of all but self
ID is incorrect
because it's not just saying I can
identify however you want it's saying I
expect everyone to see me the way I see
myself which is just not gonna happen
unfortunately unless you know you fit
the criteria for what most people look
like that also identify that way there's
so much to go through here crazy like I
thought people stay on the show for like
the whole time because you guys have no
idea how insane it's gonna get it's like
okay before I want I want to make sure
we read this story that says how talk
about why you got why do you think I
can't or whatever yeah but I have to say
one thing here's a hook so you don't
leave there literally telling lesbians
that if you don't like dick you're
transphobic that's one of their purposes
that's like conversion therapy it
literally is conversion therapy so I
have a I got it I got it I got a dive in
is I had a friend who was telling me
that one of my videos was transphobic
because I agreed with the idea that
people have preferences lesbians
preference I don't know but that's part
of the problem not not that you mean it
in the bad way but when you say
preferences I see I see that word it
that's how they frame it right framing
of you choosing it's preference no it's
not a preference it's a sexual
orientation right it's not a choice no
and you don't mean it that way but they
do and they took that and they and they
yeah I had a conversation with a friend
we're no longer friends anymore this is
crazy
like I would
never disown a friend over opinions like
even crazy ones I try and sit him down
and be like here's why you're wrong and
she was telling me that one of my videos
was transphobic because I basically
agreed with the idea of orientation to
put it more correctly and she said she
said I asked her then so would you as a
female who's straight ever being a
long-term serious relationship with
someone who was biologically female but
identifies as a man and she said I think
I could learn to like that yes and that
might be true but that but I said what I
said was I was like so you're not
attracted to that now and she was like
no but you know I could learn and I'm
like you can't learn that's conversion
there you couldn't you can recognize
your attraction but it's not learned you
don't you haven't you don't but
sometimes it's sometimes you don't know
it's there until you see it right that's
possible sometimes sometimes people
don't even know they're gay until
they're 40 right until they have the
experience and like is that valid I
guess so like I didn't have to have an
experience I just knew I was gay since I
was nine I guess the same way that I
knew I was straight like you have a
feeling towards somebody and you just
know so let's let's let's we'll come
back to this because this is such crazy
I can't believe this is a real thing but
this is the story from pink news I'm
using pink news on purpose because it's
kind of a smear against you I mean they
all oh yeah this is the only one that
that besides all the crazy activists
that posted a hate piece the other two
websites were standing up for me right
so I also have post-millennial yes it's
really funny cause like it's you're
basically gonna put out a video where
you're leaving the left tomorrow and
it's it's like I think we were talking
about it and you were saying that you
were more conservative or something that
effect and I'm like you're not though
you're the same person you've always
been your your politics are the same but
because these people are the are the
left they're the loudest they dominate
the space and they say these things now
you feel like a conservative you're not
a conservative trust me yeah I'm sure
the concern of watching or like this
takes on a concern and the other thing
too is you never misgender people like
it's interesting to me because I always
you know I'm always someone who's like
I'll use I'll use pronouns to be
respectful in certain circumstances
but that we were talking earlier and I
was like I will not use a pronoun for
that one for that particular person and
you would so it's like I feel like I'm
even a little bit to the right of you on
that issue so you are pretty lefty on
the stuff but they've gone so nuts
because I mean it's a lot let's read
this no but the point I was gonna say is
like post-millennial typically takes I
don't want to say the right I guess
because it's like a weird I don't know
the left and right really has become
anymore but it's so weird to me that you
are a lesbian LGBT activist og youtuber
you've done videos with like Blaire
white a transgender youtuber and I'm
like why are the isn't it weird that the
Trump supporters and the Conservatives
are the ones giving us a thumbs up
saying like you go more power to you and
it's the left being like burn the
waiting Shh I'm not surprised because
I've seen I've seen this I've been doing
this for so long I saw this coming
slowly and then it just blew up all at
once around 2017 it blew up 2016 22nd
regime it got crazy and then thank God
Blair came onto the scene and calmed it
all down okay how is this alright let's
let's do this okay we'll pull up this
story from pink news so originally I
guess the title was a smear they called
you a set what did they say that
originally I thought it said self
proclaimed trans folk that could have
been an assault
they could have been in the tweet that
they posted about the article - it might
have been so how long is this I don't
want to it's not that long
alright let's let's let's read this
alright so pink News says Arielle
Scarcella runs an LGBT centered YouTube
channel with over six hundred and thirty
thousand subscribers she has long been
criticized for her anti-trans views
which are expressed in detail in video
such as quote I won't apologize for
being transphobic in that video I talked
about how like not liking male genitals
isn't transphobic if you're as bein and
so basically like it's just that's
that's a trap they've laid for you
though because trans women are women and
if you're a woman and if you're if
you're a woman that's a lesbian that
likes women
you should be attracted to trans women
and you couldn't be attracted to a trans
woman if they look you know female quote
this is gonna sound bad but female
enough yeah for me that's what a lesbian
is like to me if they have any if they
have any male characteristics I'm not
gonna be attracted to it and that for me
it even goes as far as like butch
lesbians that the not that they look
male
but they look masculine right and I'm
not even into that I like feminine women
so here's the way I interpret why you
titled a video that way because you're
using the way they interpret transphobic
and you're saying I'm not gonna
apologize for what you call me that's
exactly right
yes and so naturally another sorry
you're smart well but like but I'm sure
everyone watching understands this too
like why because they're all smart but
but I think these people know as well
and they're laying a trap they go oh you
got you she admits it she's a transfer
so so what is this so first they just
say like a video she made in 2018 and
entitled or just title that's the copy
editor guys
dear trans women stop pushing quote girl
dick on lesbians yeah and that one led
to several top lesbian media outlets
publishing an open letter in
condemnation of vitriolic attacks on
trans women the funny thing about this
can I comment like yeah of course most
of the people hating on me
aren't trans women they're not there
they're just young entitled progressive
queer I bet they're all heads I bet
they're mostly like white suburban ie
straight girls yeah like a trans oh if
you're a trans woman to me like you
should respect other women like where is
this coming from you know it's like a
weird I mean it's it's all part of the
same new woke far-left ism yeah and it's
like big cults and there's no real rules
other than just fall in line
you have default they could okay I'll
give you really good example of this
years ago I unknowingly so dated a trans
guy so they presented female they were
female they presented as a woman they
told me they were woman they told me
they were a lesbian we dated then they
came out as trans we broke up you're a
man I'm not gonna date a man you're
transitioning I'm not doing it I'm a
lesbian so it's like this was someone
who was born female female to male yeah
after we broke up they transitioned I
don't know what they haven't spoken to
them in 7 years or something by people's
logic by the by the you know the
activists logic today I would be
considered bisexual or straight no
bisexual because I dated a man right
technically by their stance or you were
in at you RNA had a row sexual relations
in a head
sexual relations not like no are you
crazy but literally this is where they
will say but that doesn't it makes even
less sense when somebody says that their
gender fluid
because if your gender changes every few
weeks does my sexual orientation change
yes according to how you feel like what
how entitled is that mindset so that
that it's very much so and what's
interesting is that it shows that self
ID makes no sense if you're or if you're
orientation regardless of how you
identify change is because their
identity change that's my point so it's
like how can you so is it interesting
cuz I I knew somebody who a long time
ago identified as a lesbian then start
dating a guy and so I was like sorry you
bi and she got really mad no no and I'm
like you identify as a lesbian but
you're dating him you're a man like in a
normal heterosexual relationship I was
like I don't understand why it's a big
deal for you like it was about self ID
it was about her wanting to be as she
said she's right and I'm like what's
wrong with saying you're bi there's a
lot of fight that's done as that is
actual biphobia a phobia it is know that
that's legitimate biphobia we got away
when you're when you're afraid to admit
that you like both sexes like I had
never heard by phobia until today
because of that congresswoman in
California or whatever did you hear that
story I I saw it like really quickly
yeah yeah so what was it Katie Hills in
her name Katie oh yeah she's blaming
like biphobia so it's like I I had not
heard this but I think it's the context
it's very easy to understand what my
phobia means yeah it's like bisexual
phobia like sometimes lesbians won't
want to date a bisexual woman or like I
would say more commonly it's when
straight women won't want to date a
bisexual man because they think you'd
actually gay oh god there's so much to
talk about but I it's crazy bisexual men
like it's not as common as women but we
got it we got it we'll get to the story
but but no but another thing I want to
do these are hooks you guys can't leave
you guys to ground was that it always
flows in one direction it's always like
a male person trying to go into a female
space every time every time it's it's
always a male saying there are lesbian
going to a lesbian bar it's never a
trans man going to a gay bar it's very
rare for that to happen yeah well that's
the man why because entitlement no it is
it's male it's it's that men are
generally taught to not worry about what
other people think to not worry about
being seeming intrusive so this is you
know women are if you're raised
regardless of how you identify if you
have gender dysphoria or not if you're
raised female you're raised as a woman
you're taught to act differently women
are taught generally speaking women are
taught to be more receptive to people's
feelings do you do think that it's maybe
just because guys are slightly more
aggressive definitely Cerrone well so
it's interesting the nature though your
view on it is very much so
feminist like in in so it you know
you're you're saying nurture is more I
think so yeah I think so in this in this
perspective yes I think there's a mix I
think it's kind of pretty evenly mixed
yeah
but it's interesting to hear you say the
way you describe it is because that's
the way you described it as men are
taught to be away versus men are
biologically I'm not saying you don't
think the biology is real it's typically
an actual the actual left's position all
the stuff and they're kicking you out
and you're walking away and you're one
of the like you're one of the most left
people I know culturally to be like I'm
leaving the left because of all of this
yeah so okay we'll get back to this
let's let's I'll just ask you so what
was his event
why were you canceled from it okay so
the event wasn't actually canceled okay
so Sydney Mardi Gras they have a gay and
lesbian version of it every year
apparently and I was invited for the
first time never been to Australia very
left Lefty kind of or left the LGBT
movement going on over there from what I
understand just don't almost as bad as
the UK
yeah and they invited me and I was like
I'd love to come and immediately they
announced me on the on their website and
they got crazy I'm not a crate not even
a crazy amount of backlash I think like
a thousand people signed a petition
which is really honestly not that many
people especially for a global and very
global thing like it's really not that
many people the funny thing is the
person that started the petition is a
drag queen who got into a lot of trouble
like a few weeks before for something
basically okay what happened I'll go
really quickly about this yeah what had
happened was there was I think
conservatives I believe conservative
more conservative LGBT people protesting
drag queens story time okay did your
about this story maybe in Sydney yes I
believe somewhere in Australia and
one of this guy that this guy had this
drag queen had made the petition about
me wasn't happy of you know but the
Conservatives and blasted them on
Twitter or something and got one of the
guys one of the young gay men got
bullied so bad on Twitter that he
committed suicide
yeah I heard about that yeah so and I'm
not blaming anybody for somebody else
killing themselves but still it's like
there's you know it's just funny that in
the same way he's bullying me he's
bullying this they're all bullies you
know I'm saying like yeah you have to
take responsibility at some in some way
you know so this was like a pride event
Marty it was a Mardi Gras party event
they they didn't cancel it but they
stopped promoting it like they took it
off of their website and now it's
considered a separate event so the funny
thing about it all is that this was the
only lesbian centric event in all of
Mardi Gras like they had lots of they
have lots of queer women events but this
was like if you search the word lesbian
on their website that was the only event
that came up and that's it going in it
was there was like 15 gay seventeen
queer 10 trans that's great but one
lesbian and now it's not even there and
now it's just like queer women like I'm
not a queer woman I'm kind of lesbian
and I'm known that that's what I am so
it's it's strange that we've gotten so
left that no matter Thorat Aryan yeah
like yeah yeah no Matt you have to just
completely agree with everything these
people are saying but it'sit's the
bullies it's and it's as such the funny
thing is it's such a small subset of the
LGBT community but they're so prominent
yeah and they own it they they they just
they're obsessive you know all they do
is is no matter what they come in and
turf turf drift after it's like so
you're so at this point so let's let's
we'll get to the point on this first bit
we're going to talk about you're leaving
the left for sure sure dun dun dun I
haven't called I haven't even made
videos with with any like super left
people in years so I kind of already
left right I was kind of thinking like
we were saying and I'm like I don't
think it's an overnight thing no I slow
it was slow but now I'm like I think
it's where you realize it like and
what's crazy is
you're a pretty lefty person you're not
more conservative the same is true for
me I mean actually I think it's fair to
say I've warmed up on certain issues
that typically push my conservative just
from paying attention more but
policy-wise culturally I still very much
fall on a lot of left you know what used
to be the left and now you have an
ever-increasing group of shrieking
delusional psychotic individuals on the
left like so you're putting together
this video and I've already seen some of
it and you open with one of these clips
where it's like this this woman with a
shaved head screaming at the top of her
lungs that was that Blair White's event
at Blair White's event this is insane
like I I think I think here's what I
think the LGBT community at the moment
has become I don't even know like the
word to say it's just become all instead
of having people that are actually LGBT
with differing opinions it's become all
these mentally unstable unhealthy Minds
minded people who probably actually
aren't queer and that's like I'm using
it as an umbrella term in that sense
like LGBT like we're they're not most of
these people aren't even that and I
think I think there are a lot of them
are very young kids under the age of 25
that either feel like they don't have a
place in the world or you know they just
want to be a part of something bigger
and they they want to you know morally
do something positive and be part of a
movement and you know I think it's
getting worse it is what the reason I
think so is that when you look to
Twitter YouTube so so early on in this
segment you were questioning whether
Nayak's a the word penis okay and you
were right to do so because YouTube
takes a hard line against anyone who
opposes like who deviates from what is
ridiculously puritanical so on the right
with conservatives I mean they will ban
a conservative in two seconds it's like
you've got a nun with a ruler just
waiting staring you know steely eyed at
all the conservative kids and as soon as
some of them caught like one kid coughs
whack behind her where she's not paying
attention is the left running around
screaming and shrieking atop their lungs
with crazy paranoid conspiracy
theories bullies and they're not paying
attention to it so so the way I always
explain it to people is like imagine you
have there's a parent and next to the
parent are two kids one kid on the right
covered in chocolate ice cream looks
like a total mess and the kid on the
left looks clean-cut and like you know
proper and you think one kid must be you
know all screwed up with reality as the
parent isn't giving the other kid the
ice cream so so it's probably not yet
you have a left running wild and going
insane looking increasingly unhinged
then people like you and people like me
are like we're done with this these
people are nuts
and it's because media social media
won't tell them when to stop they just
say okay so you end up with a kid
literally taking his own life
protesting drag queen story our where
were that where was the headline CNN
where was MSNBC where are these big
stories saying it's an outrage they
don't know yeah it's really sad and but
if you're conservative even a little bit
oh they will come for you in two seconds
they will lie about you they will smear
you yeah and so like you who's not even
a conservative are getting attacked in
the press people are you know insulting
you and calling you names and the
activists are making vids on YouTube
taking things out of context of course
Scarcella transphobic on YouTube and
gender yeah you'll be like how is this
transphobic it's crazy to me that we
because I were reading about this stuff
like years ago where there was a trans
woman on YouTube saying that if you're a
lesbian and you won't date a woman with
a penis
you're transphobic right like I'm like
wait and wait a minute
that made Blair White's channel Blair
white made a video protesting that was
the video I found from it's it's it's
here so man you look at the election of
Donald Trump in his victory and what
conservatives are supposed to be in the
state Trump is a bigot and he's anti
anti LGBTQ all the stuff and I'm like
man I don't know because I see you and
Blair white having a good old time
smiling you got a trans ohm you got a
lesbian and it's a Trump supporters who
are saying hear hear
for you like you know you do you you be
free and it's the left that are
screaming be pure or or burn yeah it's
it's it's a flippin it's like the
parties are changing the left has become
moral absolutists and the right is
becoming me making joke telling liberty
minded people yeah the funny thing one
of the funny things about all this is if
you look at my channel I have in my
opinion and I'm not saying this to be
you know you can just ago but like I
think I have a pretty good catalog of LG
like of trans people that have been in
my videos I've had trans people that
pass trans people that don't pass trans
guys trans girls people that realize
that they were into men even after they
transition or vice versa you know older
tree I had a 60 year old trans person on
my channel buck angel oh yeah yeah he
did adult film yeah
he's 60 50 something I've had you know
18 year old trans kids who are people
who I think a legitimately transgendered
I have genders for have been diagnosed
etc and and I still get called
transphobia because i'm promoting the
quote wrong type of trans well what's
interesting is that they say you're
attacking trans people by asking them to
stop attacking you yeah yeah oh yeah
it's it's it's it's something we see
nobody read this and you like in this
article they actually quote you what is
it saying dear trans women stop pushing
girl Dec on lesbians you're literally
saying hey you're doing something to my
community please don't do that you you
literally said do you transmit stop
doing this they accused that of being
the attack yeah wasn't it not the attack
to go to you and accuse you of being
transphobic for not dating people you
have no orientation towards or you're
not whatever
junior high school and somebody hits you
and then you hit them back and you both
get in trouble only you hit me first
I want to smack you like that's it but
it's no but they're winning they are
like so it's it's it's no it's like
someone comes up to you and punches you
in the face and then you say stop
hitting me and they say she's attacking
me and bullying me and then they come
and take you into the principal's office
or it's it's you know what it is it's
really really simple I love this analogy
because I think sargon of akkad is such
a chill
like I don't know the right word is but
he like plays dungeon dragons
he's not the kind of guy who's gonna
March so he's what I asked those aren't
familiar sargon of akkad that you
probably know him he's a youtuber he's a
liberalist
so he's like liberal minded classical
liberal and I always ask people do you
think youtubers are kind of akkad
anti-feminist is going to rally a bunch
of his D&D Magic the Gathering playing
friends to pick up crowbars and and
bricks and go march to Twitter
headquarters to smash some windows of
course not it's never gonna happen I
mean first of all he's in the UK but
sure I get it no come on the dude does
you know his British accent arguments do
you think these leftists are gonna show
up at Twitter HQ with crowbars and
bricks they've already done things like
this so what happens is you have these
companies you have like you know this in
the the Sydney gay or you know Mardi
Gras organization is probably thinking
we don't want trouble we people going
crazy so we're just gonna we're just
gonna even Ariel's never gonna show up
with angry people she's not gonna show
up with people we're gonna smash windows
they will bye bye Ariel you go exactly
the terror works
it's literally it's terrorism bully
bully yeah so they're they're
controlling a political space
well like they're you know you ever see
that comic meme it's a woman wearing
like a purple sweater with a feminist
sign on it and she's shoveling like
manure over a wall that says the
Internet and the manure says opinions
and she's flinging it over a wall and
then the next panel is the poo flea the
manure flinging back and she goes
help-help misogyny so it's basically
like they attack you then you say hey
I'm being attacked and they go she's a
trans folk and then the organization's
shut you up they tell me to shut up
every single one of them is telling me
to shut up and that's silencing somebody
that's telling that that would be the
same as a trans woman or a trans guy or
even a bisexual person it doesn't matter
black trans women whatever someone
coming to me and saying you know this
this is an experience that we're having
you know and then I talk and then I
completely ignore their their lived
experience and say oh that doesn't
matter you should shut up about it isn't
that what's happening to you now that's
exactly what's happening people like
messaging you my friends friends have
been messaging me telling me maybe just
maybe just stop doing it for a while
that's why this is that's why this keeps
happening
yep if every single person on the
internet right now like in the LGBTQ
community that that agrees with me
stood up it would stop yep it would stop
I said
that's true for anything everybody's
terrified yeah I was telling you guys
upstairs one of my favorite things to do
now it sounds so petty but it's kind of
just I have to find all this because I
whenever I tweet something that's
considered quote more rash irrational I
the next day I'll go on like if I know
it's gonna get a few hundred likes or
retweets whatever I'll go on the next
day and I'll look at my followers list
and see who on followed me they're not
our friends anyway you don't like a
woman with an opinion you don't want to
be associated with me so I'm not gonna
be associated with you anymore
like any any anyone who claims to be
your friend and then would walk away
from you over this stuff isn't it was
never your friend I agree with you yeah
people they just want to so I'll ask you
one more thing before some of the super
chats leaving the left what does that
mean for you in terms of like voting
though have you voted Democrat is that
what you normally did or support
political classes generally voted
Democrat I would say I have to look more
into it because yeah it's I wasn't
really a fan of Hillary I didn't really
like Bernie I didn't really like Barney
either right but I didn't like Trump
right so it was a party I just voted
Hillary because like oh but no I
couldn't do it well it was her or
Trump's like what was I gonna do I set
back and put my feet up and just waited
and then when Trump won I started
laughing I knew he was gonna win right I
absolutely knew he was gonna win because
there was so much attention on him
whether it was negative or positive
yep still it's still that way yep so
yeah I could never pull that lever E for
Hillary Clinton no way is that gonna
happen and so here's where on that
trumps not that bad what you hear about
him on TV all this stuff what's a c'mon
dude nah he's not that bad he says some
dumb you know
right right right guys let's be real
she's misogynistic stuff sometimes and
but but what his policies some of them I
agree with well that can I don't think
there should be open borders I don't
know I don't think that's I don't think
that's good I don't think that people
should be you know starving and killing
each other in other countries but like
why
our fault we should write what's
happening burn used to be there with you
and then he flipped I know and now
Bernie's embracing a lot of this whoa
far left whatever psychosis yeah
so for me I'm kind of like look man
Trump would never be my first choice and
he's down the list quite a bit but he's
I I don't have him off the table I just
I'm not gonna pick the guy for a lot of
reasons but there here's here's the
problem like the easiest way to explain
it cuz it is more in depth than just
this one issue but like pro-choice I've
always been a lefty I've always been
pro-choice I grew up in a city well the
Republican Party is pro-life right and
now you have there's no pro-choice
anymore you literally have pro-abortion
and pro-life like this the bills that
have come out from the left on abortion
are like shockingly insane and the
rhetoric from a lot of high-profile
personalities is in my opinion
shockingly insane and I'm pay and I pay
attention to the stuff I think what ends
up happening is that people like you and
me who like so we're speaking up about
this we're challenging it and we're
saying enough but there are a lot of
people who have the same views as we do
literally almost everybody almost every
one of my friends but not paying
attention
no they just won't talk about it they
know what's happening they just won't
talk about it's even worse they know
it's happening yeah they're afraid
they're afraid like I said they're
afraid of losing brand deals they're
afraid of losing you know the woke
points you know hey look today there
were a couple polls that came out about
Trump his approval rating just tied and
in the aggregate meeting all the polls
together high as it's ever been his
approval rating is positive now in a
bunch of different polling polling and
people are less likely to identify as
Democrat now more likely to identify as
Republican what's crazy to me is that
when you would say something like you're
more conservative I'm like you're not
though but the conservative size is
becoming a bigger tent yeah
that's nuts it's like it's like it's
like the left but it's super loud and
then it's everyone else yep yep and
they're just kind of like muted you know
what men
what bums me out is that there are
people like you mentioned they aren't
saying anything there's literally all of
YouTube they're just walking away afraid
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we're live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. and if
you want to catch the full recorded
Podcast which doesn't appear in these
clips make sure you join by clicking the
button down below become a member and
then go to the community tab of this
youtube channel and you can see all of
our full episodes don't forget to Like
share and subscribe if you want to get
more clips like this thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all in the next
show
you